mars 1969 des milliers de producteurs et
de grossistes franciliens s'installe
dans le thoune marché de rungis une
nouvelle ère pour ces professionnels qui
pendant plus d'un siècle travaillait aux
halles de paris un lieu devenu trop
étroit et insalubres prenons l'exemple
d'un commerce comme celui de la triperie
les centaines d'états l'âge s'entassent
aujourd'hui sur moi 2000 mètres carrés
et dans des conditions d'hygiène qui
sont actuellement peut-être le scandale
numéro 1 des halles de passe face à ce
scandale sanitaire et à l'encombrement
du coeur de la capitale
le transfert du marché et décider en
1959 par le président charles de gaulle
un projet gigantesque confié à monsieur
libère bout qui très tôt envisageait le
potentiel international de ce nouveau
marché par plaques de
réapprovisionnement les grandes places
étrangères les italiens sont désirez
vendre à paris des allemands pour
accueillir cette nouvelle place
commerciale un vaste terrain au
carrefour des grandes voies ferroviaires
routières et aériennes et temps
dispensable les critères auxquels
répondaient la ville de rungis à 17 km
de paris en regardant la match cup dur
agissent futur nous voyons à quel point
ces créateurs se préoccupent d'en
faciliter l'accès via sûr et libre
circulation et parking facile
les travaux débutent en 1964 en cinq ans
sur les quelques 200 hectares de terres
15 pavillons et un centre administratif
sont construits ainsi qu'une gare
routière et ferroviaire
dans la nuit du 2 au 3 mars 1969
trente mille personnes 1000 entreprises
dix mille mètres cubes de matériel et
5000 tonnes de marchandises sont
transférés à rungis
la presse parle du déménagement du
siècle ici rien à voir avec les halles
de baltard
chaque négociant dispose d'un garrot à
trois échelons les dépôts en sous sol
reliées par monte charge aux carreaux et
à laitages un bureau du vrai moderne
tout cela véhicules de transport de
marchandises lignes téléphoniques et
mails télévision la modernité et la
grande promesse du marché de rungis une
nouvelle aventure pour ces
professionnels de l'alimentation qui
exprimait tout de même un peu de
nostalgie
je quitte mes vieilles pierres mais les
habitudes nos vieux quartier des halles
et que j'avais beaucoup et les larmes ne
sont pas loin mais ça c'est du passé
ce marché est magnifique que c'est un
marché d'avenir qui sera certainement
sensationnel ce commerçant avait vu
juste en un demi-siècle marché de rungis
s'est imposé comme le plus grand marché
de produits frais au monde en 2017
le chiffre d'affaires réalisé par les
entreprises implantées sur le site
s'élevait à 9 54 milliards d'euros
[Musique]